yes all right so Xavier Neil I'm sorry I
feel like I've been talking most okay
it's really interesting
so Xavier Neil is my new favorite
billionaire so this is my second section
this is my segment of the show called my
new favorite rich guy so this guy is
essentially like a Elon Musk type of
dude in France but instead of trying to
send rockets to Mars
this guy just operates in his own style
but he's got the same kind of alcohol
like no [__] give him attitude like a
Branson or an Elon Musk
and I never heard of this guy so I'll
tell you how I discovered him so I
discovered him because he created this
thing called 42 have you ever heard of
the school called 42 no so it waits to
me in France he's in France he so I'll
tell you his kind of like life story so
age 19 he creates this business called
minitel minitel is essentially a sex
hotline a phone service you call it so
calling someone a sex line and at 19 he
creates this thing and it goes
gangbusters and so he's doing really
well makes a few million bucks off this
then he either creates or investing
bye-bye as a stake in something called
world net sold a few years later for 50
million bucks right before the dot-com
crash and then his big thing that he did
was he created this thing called free
and free was like a t-mobile it's like a
mobile carrier and at the time in France
all like SMS phone plans are all very
expensive so he created that he undercut
everybody he created the like lowest
cost way to have you know a cellular
cellular service and so 3d became this
huge company and so his net worth
ballooned to like six point six billion
dollars I'm looking him up now this
guy's my favorite person ever yeah he's
he's very legit and so he was like
alright look what I want to do now I
want to do more baller [__] and so he
was like okay I'm gonna create this
thing called 42 so he was like I'm gonna
create a computer science school with no
teachers and no staff so all he did was
create those dopes facility with a bunch
of computers and if you get into 42 you
just come and the computer is your
lesson plan so it's like a video game
there's like a challenge it's like hey
you need to make a
that could be x y&z you're like okay and
it's like you have the internet and you
have some people next to you and like
you guys need to figure out how to get
past this level and so you start doing
the program and so it's self-serve you
do it you do a bunch of like projects to
level up plus you create your own you
know like projects or ideas so somebody
created I don't know like somebody could
create like a coronavirus tracker right
now because that's a timely little
website you can yeah I'm looking it up
now they have 2,500 students yeah and
it's actually closed right now because
the physical facility it closed here but
it was a wild idea I don't even know how
successful it's been I don't think it's
been a wild success but I love his bet
so he was like yeah I'm gonna put a
hundred fifty million dollars into this
so he built one in France and he built
one here in Fremont for a hundred
million dollars in California and it was
just like so what a rep with a radical
idea what a way to bet your money and
try to like change the world over and
over and over again and then he did this
thing in in France he's like okay how do
I build like startup ecosystem here so
he created this thing called station F
and if you just think it's like the
[__] NASA facility it's like this
huge huge but like I don't know how many
football fields long office or hanger or
co-working space and he's like alright
I'm gonna make the dopest place for any
investor to come when they're in Europe
here here's some space to go hang out
entrepreneurs you're starting companies
come over here and build your company
here's an office space restaurants come
here at the bottom fill this place up
you know gym whatever so he created his
own little oasis how like Tony Hsieh did
in Vegas this guy did in France this
guy's amazing agent F what what I just
love this guy style so first of all I've
looked it up now he's not perfect 2004
he was indicted and detained for a month
for misuse of company assets which
occurred in several of his sex shops
that he was a shareholder in and he
ended up getting a two-year suspended
prison sentence for misuse of company
assets so he's certainly not perfect I
don't know I'm just reading about this
one thing though in addition to all this
he owns the rights of the song my way by
Frank Sinatra which I love the only one
of the largest newspapers in France it
was super interesting guy what I'm
curious about people like this and
Andrew Wilkinson is gonna be on the pot
is he gonna be on unless you say
yeah next the next episode basically so
Andrew kind of Andrew not exactly but
kind of does a soy in the same way as
well until we have to ask him about this
what I want to know is how do these
people manage so many freaking projects
right cuz like I I can't even manage
what I have on my plate and like right
so it's nice never live it so they you
know they hire hire people to run their
[__] right so like I worked with a guy
Michael birch who's kind of like this
like billionaire type of dude and he
created this incubator with his totally
different model or everybody owns all
the equity in all the projects and you
know he picked me to run this around the
show for him so he truck and he trusted
me he's pretty hands-off we checked in
but like he let me run the show so I was
looking at this guy Xavier Neil and he's
got somebody this woman from Google who
runs station after being the big
facility he's got somebody who runs his
investment fund and the guy that guy was
telling the story goes you know we don't
have board meetings but I was like
Xavier don't you want to know what I'm
doing with your fund and say yeah sure
tell me and he's like he goes I told him
I said hey we invest in all these
companies I think we should double down
on these winners and make make less
small investments and do more on the
winning company so what do you say okay
he goes he goes I'm not turned I'm not
doing this to make more money I'm doing
this to make more companies invest in
more companies I was like what he's like
he's like you could double down but
don't stop investing in new and like new
small small companies and then the other
thing that they talked about in his
thing kind of like what you're saying
how do you manage this they're showing
like the guy showed his email inbox all
the emails from this guy and I've
noticed this a lot of wealthy busy
people their emails look like text
messages so like this guy will write him
a long email about like hey we're
thinking about this plan here's what we
could do here paisan
hey okay cool or like literally it's up
to you all good it's like up but number
two the letter you okay where do I see
this screenshot there was a story I
think I was like a Forbes or Bloomberg
story or something about this guy in
there but I think this is a pretty
common thing amongst the people who do a
lot of I guess it's gonna be like if I
buy like like I'm talking about how I'm
gonna buy like a just a toy car like a
fun car I guess it'd be like the
equivalent of meat bucket
a car and like letting someone use it
and it's like dude I don't care just
make sure it comes back in one piece so
you know the thing I guess the thing I
want to clarify because when Andrews
coming on on Tuesday I'm I like Andrew
for the same reason I like this guy and
they're totally different right Andrews
not gone to jail and didn't start a sex
hotline and it's not a billionaire like
well we don't know that for sure
yeah this guy or this guy has about 20
years on but I guess like the thing the
thing that stands out to me is I respect
above all else people who do [__] their
own way people who have their own they
are original thinkers and decide to live
life on their own terms that's kind of
what I got out of this guy is I think I
feel like this guy Branson Elon Musk the
thing I like about them and they're
definitely have lots of flaws and lots
of you know messed up things that they
do but I just respect that they don't
just follow a normal societal PlayBook
they live life on their own terms they
will be they basically you know
Marshalls me do their own drum or
whatever that's what I like about them
that's what I like about Andrew he's
done it completely his way which is very
non-traditional do you think this guy
speaks good English
this French guy yeah let's uh he's
alright
[Music]